I almost feel like they build this thing
out of a fairly classic writing prompt
the last person on earth sits alone in a
house and there's a knock on the door
[Applause]
[Music]
listen boy me trying to make up my mind
what I think about this thing
has been a rollercoaster when I first
saw this episode I liked it quite a bit
I think largely on the strength of
atmosphere that opening monologue from
Capaldi some really good key moments but
unfortunately as time went on the more I
thought about it the more I started
going and then when stuff happened later
on with things like hell-bent and I kind
of looked back at this through the lens
of issues that I had later it suddenly
didn't feel like it held up quite as
well but rewatching it it does in some
areas but other things do kind of drive
me crazy
like this really is such a mixed bag and
usually when I say that it's because
there's some things that are pretty good
some things don't quite work and like it
evens out in the middle like no there's
things I really really like about this
and there's other stuff that I'm like oh
come on so let's start with that opening
sort of monologue from the doctor it's a
bit self-indulgent and something that
they will do again with Capaldi later on
during his run opening with just him
talking in the TARDIS effectively to the
audience ostensibly to himself and it's
it's kind of a okay where are you going
with this then all of a sudden just
looks at the chalkboard but first of all
introduction I'm pretty sure of the
chalkboard which love that addition to
his TARDIS makes total sense for him it
also feels like it's seeding the you
know him ultimately ending up as a
professor I feel like elements of him
having that kind of role are being laid
in as it goes along which is really cool
and I like that but any
he's coming back to it it just says on
the listen which first off it's the name
of the episode so you know title drop
but in addition like the fact that he's
just you know openly asking the question
if you could hide perfectly and never be
found what would you do and there it is
on the chalkboard I think if I were to
nail down my conflict in my head about
this episode it's that it is immensely
atmospheric some scenes are just
executed to near perfection but I'm
ultimately not sure what it's in service
of now to be clear not every episode has
to serve a greater purpose an episode
can just be a fun episode robots of
Sherwood it was basically just off on
episode curse the black spot that's
that's that's a fun one for me that's a
comfort-food episode for me not
everything has to feed a greater purpose
the thing is though this episode has
this air of importance of relevance of
depth to it
that if you're gonna invoke that kind of
feel you probably should be saying
something whether it's about bigger
philosophical things like say talking
about depression with Vincent and the
doctor and can you hear me or whether
it's teaching us something specific
about the characters that we don't
already know like we got with
Christopher Eccleston would say Dalek I
don't think this really accomplishes
either one it's an interesting sort of
it's not even I was gonna say it's a
meditation I hear but it's not it's not
a meditation on fear it's a string of
very well put together tensely scary
scenes that do a great job of playing
off fear of the unknown but it's not
really meditation on that it's just a
series of examples of it done very well
I can't wrap my head around what it
serves and again another reason
like this should be serving something is
what happens with Clara at the end and
will kind of come back to that alright
let's let's talk about some of the
brilliant scenes in this first off
Capaldi is doing very good work if
there's anything that maybe we get a
little bit of a taste from from him here
is this particular doctors tendency to
obsess a bit which is not completely
unique to this doctor but he's got it a
little bit harder than most and maybe
you could consider that's the thing that
we learn about him but I I don't know
that feels that feels flimsy because it
doesn't feel like a serious new learning
of information it actually feels pretty
organic fitting with what we've already
seen that I him do and be about up to
this point the main scenes it's that
opening that opening is fantastic and
the other scene that really really
really works the scene with Rupert young
Danny Payne for a couple of reasons
first off just the idea of checking
under the bed coming back up and
something saying on the bed under a
blanket that is simple but effective
intense as hell and I love the doctor's
speech to Rupert about fear being a
superpower I don't like at all that
Clara recycles it later on in the same
episode but anyway so I think that's why
I need I need to start picking apart
things that any one of them in isolation
might not have bothered me but the
recurring similar issues with the things
that I'm about to start talking about do
bother me especially as they start to
pile up on top of each other
there's Orson pink which actually first
of all let's back up Danny we get a
little bit more time with him a little
bit of an established of the start of
his and Clara's relationship I feel like
after establishing it initially really
well they're hammering a little too hard
on Danny
sort of well his PTSD and his prick
leanness around his own history in the
military again it's not that it's
unearned it's that I it's like they're
hitting the same nail they already kind
of hit and like a reminder was necessary
but they hit it harder this time which
I'm not sure was necessary not sure that
was needed but we are starting to see
them develop a rapport a dynamic that
works so Orson pink which is the guy who
stuck at me at the far end of time when
everything's coming apart I was gonna
say spoilers but like this is all rear
view stuff so for what happens later and
given that we know that Danny dies we
never really get an explanation on Orson
pink it is feasible that he is a
relation to Danny other than direct
straight-line descendent however he also
alludes to Clara having been in his
family line and while you could account
for him being related to Danny without
Danny necessarily having to still be
around to connect him to Clara like wait
a minute this by itself could be hand
waved as there are certain people
certain events that are fixed points in
history will always happen we're always
going to happen you can't really change
it or you can try it but it's gonna go
badly and maybe Orson pink isn't one of
them so he was supposed to happen but
since Danny dies maybe now he never does
that leaves a massive dangling plot
thread that never really gets tied up or
addressed in any meaningful way
and then we have the addition of what
happens at the very end and like here's
the thing and I don't know if Moffat
himself has offered these up as like
ways to try and get out of jail on these
on these logistical issues but I've seen
people say things like well it maybe it
wasn't the doctor in that barn maybe it
was some other time maybe it was the
master I'm like well yeah but what
purpose would that serve if it's not the
doctor then what's the point of the
scene especially given that Clara
connects this barn as the barn that the
war doctor came back to now in addition
to how Clara got intertwined in his
timeline
before with the name of the doctor
they're now doing it again at an even
earlier point because before there were
a couple things that that allowed name
of the doctor to get away with what it
did the first really what she was doing
was undoing the damage done by the great
intelligence so while one could make an
argument that the doctor picked the
TARDIS that he did because Clara was
there to point him in that direction or
that you know she actively saved every
doctor up you know at some point in
their lives
or you could equally argue that all she
did was reverse whatever the great
intelligence had done and maintained the
timeline as it had always been meaning
the doctor keeps his agency in his
history that's the first thing and the
second thing which I I'm bringing up in
comparison to listen is that it starts
with his adventuring now we are
connecting Clara to his childhood before
he was the doctor before he was even
clearly on the path to being a Time Lord
now she's there saying a shortened
version of the speech we heard the
doctor give to Rupert which also sucked
some of the strength out of that because
you can argue that the doctor doesn't
remember because he was so young and
even if I buy that it still means that
this idea is now not purely of his own
it's now cyclical and arguably was an
idea he got from Clara it's a pair it's
now instead of a great speech from the
doctor it's a paradoxical time Luke then
who knows where it came from
but I liked it coming from the doctor
because it fit the sort of thing that he
would have just said if that speech had
been out of character for the doctor
then something like this where she goes
back to when he's very young and says
something very similar to that that
would have been a neat little circle
around to be like oh that's why he said
that when I wouldn't have normally
thought he would have said something
like that
okay but instead the speech is 100% in
character and now it's become a little
reciprocal self-feeding loop because
because Moffat felt like he wanted to be
clever with it and it's just one more
thing that bakes Clara into his history
and you did it once and I kind of like
was prepared to roll with it I have my
head Canon for how I could accept it so
it wasn't gonna bother me too much but
now you're doing it again and I don't
know why you're doing it again
and it feels like and I know this isn't
literally what's going on I'm not this
egotistical but it's like it feels like
you're baiting me it's like you did a
thing but I was kind of iffy about but I
found a way to square that circle I was
okay but then you basically did a very
similar version the same thing again now
I'm like do you want me to figure out a
way to make this work for me are you
just trying to hammer into me that it's
supposed to be something that I'm not
going to like and you're not gonna let
me figure out how to make this work in a
way that that I can digest and am okay
with it doesn't it start to feel like at
this point despite a phenomenal
performance from Capaldi I actually good
performances from everybody
both Danny and arts and pink are good or
something especially really good sense
of quiet dread about him he does that
very well and Clara gives a good
performance and and you know some of
these scenes are masterfully executed
but overall I'm just left going why and
again not every episode has to have a
purpose but this thing has this air of
importance about it so it seems to think
it has a purpose a dang to find out what
it is so let's listen yuri watched it
lately would you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something on down
in the comments well let's talk about it
usual stuff - do you know what it is
like subscribe share this around with
friends I have a patreon I'm on Twitter
or all sorts of stuff links down in the
description click on them they'll take
you places or you also don't have to
because end of the day you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]